alright guys here we are in a
Jeep Wrangler try to move this around so
we don't
too much glare really not a whole lot to
see on the tester we dropped our
glovebox down we got our ATC 2011
plugged in right there and a star
connector this just drops down right
here you can see see if I can grab my
flashlight this right there is just held
in just push that's being held and then
there's a little clip right there on
this side you just kind of slide it from
down here up comes right off just like
that and then you can access your star
connector so let's push to start this is
a spare key but we got nothing in the
vehicle so we're gonna go ahead and
program nisshin's off hazards are on
we've got two Q's in it already just go
to program procs I'm sorry guys bear
with me here with the glare okay
okay put it back over here if it'll make
any difference a little further away but
all right after pressing okay we're
gonna press and hold the props to be
programmed which is this one right here
up against the start/stop button using
corner press and hold the button down
and watch the screen so we got our it
says off right there we're gonna go
ahead and hit it
says please wait okay we release it will
hold it still in front three cheese
program just like that okay I will go
ahead and disconnect move our tester out
of the way over here everything logged
in but as you can see I haven't caught
it or anything somebody key on the
lock there there it is 2020
Jeep Wrangler push the start
spare key or all keys loss makes no
difference
you